so how did you guys meet
well at school
um childhood sweetheart yeah 16. and
then the year after when you were age 17
we met yeah how did that come about um
so i was doing an apprenticeship at an
estate agents
um and i basically came across your
youtube and um
saw that the crash course was going on
jake didn't really you didn't really
have just dragged me along to the crash
course and
yeah i was like i'm not going to london
and i'm 17. so jugged him along what
could happen who could you make yeah
yeah dragged him along and then when we
were there
um basically discovered rent to sa what
did you think when you heard about the
concept did you think did you think oh
that makes sense or were you skeptical
better both really but
for us the rent i say made a lot of
sense especially when we live in
bournemouth it's great for tourism yeah
holiday essential isn't it so you're 17
years old you're at the property
investors crash course you've just
learned about rent-to-service
accommodation
we i mean were you not thinking that
sounds great but we're 17. yes
so so there's obviously some extra
hardships when you're young when you're
starting did you have much money did you
have much saved we had about grand each
week
a little bit of money yeah um so what
what what were the next steps then so
what what what happened the crash course
because i know now you've gone on to
build a nice little rent to rent
portfolio financially free yeah
full-time in property and you've done
incredibly well but what was it that
happened
over those couple of days with me where
it was like i'm gonna actually do this
yes i think it's where you said like
you're gonna get told no a lot right and
that basic because we got told now about
what 10 times when we're 17 landlords
look at you like no chance
don't take it seriously yeah at all
really and we didn't have any background
like it was basically like oh hi we're
17 can we rent your property and rent
out please and they're like
uh with what like credentials and we're
like none
um so
yeah we got told no about 10 times
um but where you said like
you're gonna be told no a lot we were
just like right keep going then keep
going and then we finally had a really
chilled landlord and was like yeah cool
take it for three years we still got
that one now actually
so how did that work then so where is it
and talk me through the figures and the
detail in the setup how you found him
what happened well it's perfect location
it's literally a minute walk from
bournemouth pair itself right around the
corner it's next to like it's a new
build it's a new build it was literally
perfect where how did you find the
landlord we went on um right now it was
through an agent actually right um and
they were basically just like yeah
that's fine because they just basically
took our um
reference from our job as well so we
sort of had to do
part
company let and then they wanted
obviously where we had nothing yeah they
wanted our um right you to be a
guarantor yeah right for yourselves yeah
for the company
um so how much rent did you pay for that
first property per month what did you
agree so it was 7.50 but then it's only
just recently it's gone up to 775. so
the time of 75th day and you were and
you just turned 18 at this point and you
both got jobs yeah a full-time job
estate agent right and i was in retail
yeah
okay cool so you used your income to put
down as like to back that you could
afford it
750 a month and then you got you had
permission from the landlord to do it
through service accommodation we were
like literally at lunch times like
meeting going cleaning the property
because we were like right let's make as
much money as possible yeah now we've
got cleaners in place but um yeah at
that point um but yeah we were
we make about
two thousand pounds a month profit off
that property
it does it's our best it's our best one
for sure
yeah so you pay 700 to 750 sorry now 775
to the landlord but then you rent it out
for like thousands of pounds yeah so
that's after like all bills as well we
make 2 000
pounds
and then you've got another one and
another one you just secured
six recently yeah pretty much so we've
got yeah well for the first two years we
had two properties that one in
bournemouth and then we managed a cabin
in the new forest right and then in the
start of this year we just got four more
yeah one's got a pool as well
so have you literally just been doing
this
this has been your full-time income
so i left so actually off so when locked
down here i got put on furlough for
eight months um and we were just like
right let's try getting more track and
then we just kept being told no no no no
no um we were like right what are we
gonna do so
i actually got another part-time job at
my stables like with the horses
um and then i was doing that and then in
august i left that and now like doing
this full-time so you've been doing this
full-time now for about
almost coming up to a year yeah almost i
like you jack jd sports no no more full
time on it now but at the start of the
year i left jd sports and
put all my eggs in
the business so
did you guys feel like you got a bit
lucky or do you think that you've just
learned the system and applied it i
think to be honest the first one was
luck i think a bit of both but the first
one was definitely and then yeah
yeah
yeah and then after that it has like i
feel like we do sort of know inside out
now like yeah well the fact that you've
gone and got multiple more i mean the
first one is it is an absolute gem yeah
but the thing is as well like you went
out and did it didn't you yeah so when
you go out and you knock on doors and
you call agents and you say the scripts
i just can't get over the fact that you
came to the property versus crash course
when you were 17. yeah that's just
mind-boggling where did that drive come
from like what did what was it that made
you think i want to travel all the way
to london 17 years old thousand pound in
my pocket so my parents are
entrepreneurs they've got
businesses and i've always i don't know
if it's right or wrong but i've always
thought i'm not working for someone else
um like i will work for myself like i
like all growing up i was like i don't
care what it is or like
i don't know what it is yet but i will
be
working for myself
what have you got to lose it was a free
crash course yeah i feel like at 17 is
the best time because it's like you
don't have a house to lose like still
living at home like you can put
everything you've got into it and we'll
start a grand you can just make that
back
yeah what does it feel like working
together full time on your own business
not having to worry about having a job
we thought we'd be fighting like cat and
dog but actually not
yeah
great yeah and you messaged me recently
on instagram yeah um and just summarize
what was it that you said to me like a
couple of weeks i was basically just
like thank you so much because this was
basically after we were just
so we were sort of working with a
developer and bournemouth
large landlord
and he sort of
like basically given us as many as we
want
um so as time goes on we'll hopefully
take more from him
um
but
yeah so it was after like everything on
that was agreed and like we just paid
the first month and i was like you know
i'm gonna message you because
i actually didn't know even what this
structure of a business was until we
went to the crash course yeah so it is
all bound to you you know what i really
appreciate that because it gives me
reason to keep doing what i'm doing when
people you know i get messages regularly
you know every day from people saying
similar stuff and that's what gives me
the drive of the energy to keep going
keep putting out content keep running
property training even if it is free um
so what would you say has been the most
challenging point when was there any
moments where you thought oh my goodness
this is difficult i might quit i think
when we both went full time and you're
having to rely on
purely the business for an income we're
a bit like what have we done you should
maybe just for security and then we're
looking for more properties you're then
having to put rent deposit down which is
like would
pretty much like but then i think our
mindset has changed that we're now like
well it has to work so yeah it has to
work you've got no choice now it's got
nothing to fall back on and now the
money that you're making i imagine is a
lot more than you would be if you were
in a job yeah absolutely i mean how much
with these i know the the some of the
properties that you've got are quite new
and you do need a few months to sort of
be able to see exactly how much you're
making but how much are you projecting
how much are you expecting to be making
from all of the portfolio now in total
per month um probably about ten thousand
ten ten to twelve well summer it will be
a bit more because we up our prices um
but yeah it'll be about ten to twelve in
july i believe yeah
um august will be probably about the
same
yeah summers like then the quality
months
bring it back down maybe about seven to
six yeah but that's an incredible i mean
to earn that kind of money generally
you'd have to go to university for six
seven years yeah qualify as a as a as a
lawyer work your way up the ranks you
have to be a barrister yeah well funnily
enough when i was at college and i was
doing an equine i was like i'm going to
be a vet so i'm going to go to uni blah
blah blah you never made that question i
was like uh seven years at uni i don't
think so
i was like i need to look at other stuff
yeah but yeah what's it like
in terms of lifestyle like how how how
has your lifestyle changed would you say
there's so much more freedom isn't it it
is but then we also
haven't got a day off a messaging guest
24 7 right so it is yeah a full-time job
it's almost like that's the thing isn't
it it's it's freedom from having to go
to work and yeah but then it's lifestyle
i don't mind working for myself like
genuinely i don't mind working full-time
for myself when do you think you'll hire
your first full-time member because you
could hire somebody yeah and then
instead of making 10 grand you might
make seven grand but it'll be completely
passive yeah well that is the next step
really i think we just won a few more
maybe yeah and then
yeah we can
start doing other strategies like
packaging and selling deals and we have
looked into it i think to be honest we
need a bit more education before we go
into that when we first came on the
crash course we did actually look at
hmos first right but we
saw service accommodation and we thought
that was best suited for us where the
location we are yeah yeah but we
definitely will look into other things
amazing and also buying stuff as well
maybe buying down run down a
rundown house it into luxury apartments
we financed it yeah the whole thing out
a service department well it's yours
suddenly enough we were speaking to a
mortgage advisor a couple months ago
because we had quite a big chunk of
money yeah and we were going to buy
something but then we met this developer
and he was basically like take as many
rents rents as you want right so we were
basically like okay let's put all our
money into that thing because then that
can create more money yeah so and that's
the difference the thing is in property
i always say this you've got you've got
a property business which is trading
fast cash flow and then you've got
property investments and right now you
guys are young so you're focusing more
on the business side of it to get the
cash flow up and then once you're making
a load of bucket load of money you and
then stop building your own portfolio
um
so so what would you say has been the
biggest lesson if you were kind of
advising your three-year younger self
when you were just finishing school what
would you say to yourself
just starting out in this journey don't
be scared just give it a go yeah like
because otherwise we wouldn't be in the
situation we are now if we never gave if
we never
came to the crash course and then we
never gave service accommodation to go
yeah it's basically just what is there
to lose exactly yeah like coming out of
school what is that to lose you may as
well put you all into something rather
than going the safe route of
no i've got to get a full-time job i've
got to do that like i do sort of wish we
did it earlier really
get out of here guys honestly because
i've like
like even just working like you could we
could have done it earlier we could have
been a year ahead of us well wow yeah
but i think you did it pretty early
it always makes me um
curious when people set like a gap year
yeah travel and stuff i think why don't
why doesn't everybody take a gap year to
financial freedom once you've made money
as well you can enjoy it more well yeah
but but what i'm talking about is if
people can take a gap year just to
travel which is fine why can't everybody
take a gap year to financial freedom i'm
going to spend one year
i can always go to uni later yeah right
when i leave school i'm going to spend
one year and i'm going to get trained
and i'm going to go crazy and i'm going
to try the different property strategies
and if it doesn't work then i got some
experience from it if it does work i can
cancel that unique five-year uni plan i
can cancel that and i can live the rest
of my life
on my terms yeah one of the things that
people probably might think on this
video watching this interview so i want
to just address it
because you're young and because you're
so successful is i bet your mom and dad
have given you loads of money and helped
you out and so i mean if if that was the
case it wouldn't be a problem but i just
wanted to address it talk to me about
parents involvement we haven't had a
penny
it's all been our own money that started
it um that my parents are quite big on
like
if you need us
like really really need us if you're in
the prison cell i'll come back yeah but
you need to make your own money like you
go out yeah that's good so like they
will be there if needed if you know what
i mean but we haven't had any money i
wouldn't see you on the streets yeah
yeah
yeah oh wow okay how about yourself oh
my parents were being supported but
i haven't seen one penny and i don't
really want to i want to make it myself
yeah that's the best kind of parents
best kind of parenting is just to
believe and support but not to
necessarily give big handouts
um incredible what did was it were there
people at the beginning though um not
necessarily parents but just friends
family colleagues school friends
whatever
that were like what are you doing you're
crazy yeah and i think sometimes when
we're up at
three in the morning dealing with guests
that maybe aren't happy with something
they're a bit like is it worth it like
is it worth that 100 pound a night or
whatever and i'm like
well yeah it is really in the long run
and also i i think with essay what's
good is you can
if you have a bad guest
it's
a stress for maybe a week if you've got
a bad tenant it's a stress for
months that's right so it's like a good
return almost
yeah that's true
how did you feel though when you when i
mean even even when you started out i'm
also thinking as well because a lot of
people i mean yes you when you got your
business
and you're up till three with a bad test
people might be like what are you doing
i don't envy you but what about when you
started out before you made the leap
what were the general consensus from
friends school family like what was the
i mean i don't think they really got it
yeah i think they're a bit like okay
because a lot of them are nine to five
that's all they live for they just look
for the paycheck at the end of the month
there's nothing
wrong with that
but we like to work for ourselves we
like to yeah get our own money and yeah
because i think it must be so hard i
have such respect for you guys but when
people step out and and they've got
people around them like what are you
doing yeah especially when you're young
it must be so for me it was quite
daunting luckily i had some people in my
family that were really supportive my
mom was really supportive but there's a
lot of people that were not and it's
just interesting because it's it's um
you know you're so young i'm just i'm
just curious what would you say um what
would you say your steps are now like
what are you wanting to do next what's
the what's the plan i think
more essays as much as
we're doing as much as we can and then
we would like to buy eventually and
start buying our own yeah um and we
would like to look into other avenues as
well
like deal sourcing and stuff but as i
said i think we do need a bit because
we've only had the free you did what
we've only had the free training yes so
we've done this off the free training
that's crazy yeah so
what can we do with page training i know
and that's another thing as well because
when obviously when you can you're 17
years old um and you didn't have loads
of money and stuff but like sometimes
people think oh there's no point going
to the property investors crash course
because i'm just going to get sold
an
expensive mentorship program or whatever
and it's like well no
the crash course and the free training
in and of himself are brilliant
of course there's options to do further
training and of course i'm going to sell
i'm going to be like head this is i'm
going to sell the advanced training but
the the free training in and of itself
is ridiculously good yeah um i think if
we did sorry if we did do the paid
training we would have probably fast
forward our
success
but
still
like we've got here and we're 20 with
just the free training of yours so
yeah it's obviously what was it about
those two days that you spent with me
for free that was so
because you keep referring back to it
like what was it about those two days
that happened or the experience that was
so um impactful in your business
was
you were always saying about energy
bring energy and it was us getting out
of our comfort zone really because we
were
arrived we sat at the back and we were
quite nervous didn't want to get
involved just wanted to watch and not do
anything but then you made us go into
teams find deals and stuff like that
yeah so we sort of had to like
because we'd never obviously done
anything like that i was 17. yeah so
like speaking to strangers and like
working with strangers and it sort of
did as good really so i think
learning how to create relationships
even
like helped
yeah because when people come to the
courses sometimes that a lot of people
like to come sit at the back and and
it's like no this is not a seminar this
is a do-it-all yeah you're going to be
on the phones man you're going to we
learned by the end and we were sort of
creeping for our tours yeah but yeah at
the start we were like
and everyone like yeah we were obviously
really young yeah yeah so you're 20
years old now you've got six rent to
rent you're financially independent
you're both full-time in property um
huge
respect to what you've done i know we'll
see you on the advanced training later
on and we can start scaling and do
different things but the fact that
you've done that from the crash course
is just absolutely incredible what would
your final words of wisdom and advice be
to anyone watching this that's thinking
i want to do the same thing i want to
get into property what would be your
best piece of advice just give it a go i
think as we've said throughout what was
there to lose like
give it a crack basically
especially if you can start with as
little like no money basically yeah then
what are you losing like you may as well
give it a go well done good respect well
done thank you
[Music]
you